>>> TONIGHT UKRAIN RUSSIA AND
E WORLD ARE MARKING 0 DAYS
OF WAR.
100 DAYS OF HORRORS INFLICTED BY
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S INVASION WITH
NO CLEAR VICTORY IN SIGHT FOR
EITHER SIDE.
LET'S GO TO OUR SENIOR
INTERNATIONAL CORRESPONDENT BEN
WEDEMAN JOINING US LIVE FROM
KYIV RIGHT NOW.
BEN, GIVE US THE LATEST ON
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE GROUND
AND WHERE THIS WAR SEEMS TO BE
HEADING NEXT.
>> Reporter: WELL, THE CRITICAL
BATTLE RIGHT NOW, WOLF, IS IN
THE EASTERN DONBAS REGION, AND
PARTICULARLY IN THE CITY OF
SEVEREDONETSK POUNDED BY RUSSIAN
ARTILLERY AND 80% OF THAT CITY
IS NOW UNDER RUSSIAN CONTROL.
NOW, THERE ARE STILL UKRAINIAN
FORCES OPERATING IN SMALL
POCKETS IN THE CITY, PERHAPS
JUST TRYING TO COVER A RETREAT
BY THE UKRAINIAN FORCES BUT
CERTAINLY WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS
THAT EVEN IN PLACES LIKE THAT
AFTER THIS INTENSE ARTILLERY
BOMBARDMENT THERE IS STILL
INTENSE UKRAINIAN RESISTANCE,
NOW, WE UNDERSTAND THAT AS MANY
AS 800 PEOPLE, CIVILIANS ARE
STILL HIDING OUT IN A CHEMICAL
PLANT IN THE BASEMENT, RATHER,
THE BOMB SHELTERS THERE.
WE WERE IN THOSE BOMB SHELTERS
BACK IN APRIL.
THE SITUATION WAS DIRE BACK
THEN.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT IT IS
NOW.
NOW, THE UKRAINIANS, HOWEVER,
ARE SAYING THAT THEY -- WITHIN
THE LAST 24 HOURS, HOWEVER, THE
RUSSIANS HAVE NOT MADE ANY MAJOR
ADVANCES WITHIN THAT CITY
ITSELF.
THEY DO, HOWEVER, WARN THAT
RUSSIAN FORCES ARE MASSING
OUTSIDE THE CITY ELSEWHERE IN
DONBAS PREPARING TO RETAKE THAT
CITY DESPITE THESE PROBLEMS,
PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY
DID COME OUT AND SAY THAT HE IS
CONFIDENT THAT IN THE END,
UKRAINE WILL BE VICTORIOUS.
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
>> Translator: THE LEADERS OF
PARLIAMENTARY FACTIONS ARE HERE.
THE PRESIDENT'S CHIEF OF STAFF
IS HERE.
THE PRIME MINISTER OF UKRAINE IS
HERE.
THE PRESIDENT IS HERE.
OUR TEAM IS MUCH BIGGER.
THE ARMED FORCES OF UKRAINE ARE
HERE.
MOST IMPORTANTLY OUR PEOPLE, THE
PEOPLE OF OUR COUNTRY ARE HERE.
WE HAVE BEEN DEFENDING UKRAINE
FOR 100 DAYS.
VICTORY SHALL BE OURS, FLORY TO
UKRAINE.
>> AND WHEN YOU THINK BACK,
WOLF, TO HOW DIRE THIS SITUATION
WAS IN UKRAINE, 90 DAYS AGO WHEN
WE UNDERSTOOD THAT THERE WERE
MULTIPLE PLANS BY THE RUSSIANS
TO ACTUALLY ASSASSINATE
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, THAT HE'S
NOW EVERY DAY, EVERY EVENING
COMING OUT WITH THESE
STATEMENTS, IT SHOWS THAT
CERTAINLY THE SITUATION HAS
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY FROM WHAT
IT WAS JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO,
WOLF.
>> GOOD POINT.
BEN WEDEMAN ON THE SCENE IN
KYIV.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> LET'S GET THE BIG PICTURE
RIGHT NOW, WHERE THE WAR STANDS
100 DAYS IN, BRIAN TODD IS
JOINING US ALONG WITH CNN'S
MILITARY ANALYST RETIRED MAJOR
GENERAL JAMES "SPIDER" MARKS.
>> HOW HAVE THEY GAINED MORE
GROUND DURING THE COURSE OF THE
CONFLICT.
>> NO BETTER WAY THAN WITH A
MAP.
GENERAL MARKS, WE WILL SHOW
VIEWERS AS WE GET 100 DAYS INTO
THE WAR WHAT THE MAP LOOKED LIKE
ON MARCH 5th.
GENERAL.
THIS IS THE WAY IT LOOKED.
RUSSIANS PINCHING IN ON KYIV
FROM AT LEAST THREE SIDES AND
HELD SOME TERRITORY IN THE
NORTHEAST.
THIS IS THE WAY THE MAP LOOKS
TODAY.
NOW, GENERAL, HOW HAVE THE
RUSSIANS CHANGED THEIR STRATEGY?
WHERE ARE THEY MAKING THEIR
BIGGEST GAINS RIGHT NOW?
>> YEAH, WELL, BRIAN, WHAT'S
REALLY HAPPENING IS THE RUSSIANS
BACK IN THE EARLY PART OF THE
WAR TRIED TO INVADE WITH TOO FEW
FORCES ALONG TOO MANY AVENUES OF
APPROACH, IN OTHER WORDS, THEY
TRIED TO BITE OFF MORE THAN THEY
COULD CHEW.
THEY DETERMINED THAT IN VERY
SHORT ORDER BECAUSE THEY
UNDERESTIMATED THE UKRAINIANS
AND THEY OVERESTIMATED THEIR OWN
ABILITIES.
AS A RESULT OF THAT, THEY PUT
ALL OF THEIR FORCES DOWN IN THE
DONBAS AREA AND NOW CREATED AS
THE NEW MAP SHOWS THIS CRESCENT
THAT RUNS FROM THE EASTERN
PORTION OF KHARKIV ALL THE WAY
DOWN TO KHERSON WHICH
SUCCESSFULLY CREATE, IT HAS TO
BE HELD BUT SUCCESSFULLY CREATES
THIS LAND BRIDGE FOR RUSSIA TO
CRIMEA.
>> RIGHT, GENERAL, WE'LL TALK
ABOUT THE WEAPONRY NOW.
OVER THE COURSE OF 100 DAYS IT
HAS EVOLVED.
THE U.S. AND NATO GAVE THE
UKRAINIANSLE JAVELIN MISSILES
THEN M-HYPE 17 HELICOPTERS AND
SWITCHBLADE DRONES AND SENT
HOWITZERS WITH THE UKRAINIANS
TRAINING ON THOSE AND WHAT THEY
CALL HIGH MOBILITY ROCKET
SYSTEMS WHICH THE UKRAINIANS
WANT THOSE ROCKETS TO HAVE A
RANGE OF 200 MILES, THE U.S.
GIVING THEM ROCKETS WITH ONLY A
RANGE OF ABOUT 50 MILES.
CAN THESE MAKE A DIFFERENCE,
GENERAL, AND HOW CAN THE
UKRAINIANS USE THESE?
>> WE'VE SEEN OVER THE COURSE OF
THE 100 DAYS THE SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE THIS TYPE OF KIT IS
PROVIDING THE UKRAINIANS.
WHAT IT REALLY GIVES THEM IS A
STEP-UP CAPABILITY TO FIGHT THE
UKRAINIANS TO FIGHT AGAINST THE
RUSSIANS IN DEPTH.
THAT'S THE WAY YOU SET THE
OPERATIONAL TEMPO.
CONDITIONS FOR THE TACTICAL
FIGHT AND THAT'S WHAT THESE
CAPABILITIES PROVIDE THEM.
NOW, BEAR IN MIND PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY ALONG WITH OUR OWN
PRESIDENT INDICATED WE DON'T
WANT TO FIGHT IN TO RUSSIA FROM
A MILITARY GUY'S PERSPECTIVE.
IF YOU CAN GET INTO THAT
SANCTUARY AND GO AFTER THE
RUSSIANS WHERE THE LOGISTICS
ARE, WHERE THEY REFUEL, WHERE
THEY REFIT, WHERE THEY TAKE A
BREAK, YOU CAN GET INTO THE
TEMPO THAT THEY NOW HAVE TO
BRING FORWARD TO THE BATTLE.
THE UKRAINIANS CAN SET THAT
TEMPO.
>> GENERAL, KEY QUESTION HERE.
100 DAYS IN, LET'S PROJECT WHERE
IS IT GOING TO LOOK
TERRITORIALLY 100 DAYS FROM NOW?
CAN THE UKRAINIANS RECAPTURE THE
20% OF THEIR TERRITORY FROM
RUSSIANS AT THIS POINT?
>> WELL, IT'S UNLIKELY THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO THAT, LET'S
BE FRANK.
CRIMEA EXISTED AND THE DONBAS
EXISTED WHERE RUSSIAN FORCES
HAVE BEEN SINCE 2014.
THOSE I THINK ARE GOING TO
REMAIN IN PLACE.
THE SUCCESS THAT THE UKRAINIANS
CAN ACHIEVE RIGHT NOW WILL
DETERMINE HOW MUCH MORE OF
UKRAINE THEY CAN RECLAIM.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE AT AN
INFLECTION POINT.
>> AS WE TOSS BACK TO YOU RUSSIA
ACCORDING TO PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
HAS LOST ABOUT 30,000 SOLDIERS.
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE AN
ACCURATE MARK FROM PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY, BUT THE PRESIDENT
ALSO SAYS THAT HE IS LOSING 60
TO 100 SOLDIERS A DAY, BOTH
GENERAL MARKS AND I BELIEVE HE
CAN'T TAKEN